hello Edwin asked me to say a few words
in Cantonese so I'm gonna try my best
here talking about why it's so important
in language learning to enjoy it the
main reason is that if you enjoy it
you'll spend more time at it and the
major major ingredient for success in
language learning is simply the spent
time spend the time reading listening in
with the language come see ha i wanna ha
get a community jo yo easy team ghana
yo I need Joe Young ho Yong ho seeking
equal name only
join me man they job William damned or
meseta Johnny in here
so here you go honey they [ __ ] up
getting the phone son hi OMA Towey net
they do meet oh well gee hold on I hope
how Bumgarner I totally for you three
ai-yi-yi I'm Sam
oh so it's a jaw high high sound for the
see how evil Allah the madam Joe Hana K
tally-hawk son had a tiger see huh
[ __ ] a young funnel cane area madam
toe toe Saudi a familiar daikon younger
not a madam Jang BOGO already married
Amina moja is so hot Hollis sahaja yoga
well final kiz jota to Mauna Kea young
de dos Akana
Tyson tang gala million a high Joey will
you no one home holy
sorry
Moana Tim young Hawaii I was picked on
the heart but your holy cool on that
year yeah home he'll tell you you think
that ha so you know gotta tell me give
me all the chicken the whole pong hi
Dakota Yahoo China Nagoya to yoga you
when a whole come young cool on your day
to hell
Jean dacoit educate dr. Houlihan Charlie
oh you're not sorry
McCoy able to get her home come now
hideaway you hold osika technically time
surah Thai Nguyen aye young [ __ ] you
today
come here sorry my katom I'm a cameraman
voila
my meaty drills exercise Mandela died in
your boy
Gaga walks on water he one day I think I
hope to meet with the new holy God
coq10 a cup they are easy a lot charger
how about if I never do yoga
oh come now Hamza you you meet the gang
we book Michael john-boy come by Steve
la Haven they they are merrily in a
hurry
okay the email came came on ha ha target
all right